ça fait un bon bout guillon boutin doit
absolument se trouver un logement un
endroit pour vivre avec son fils de
quatre ans la ligne est un trois et demi
je peux vraiment ma chambre dans le
salon bleu c'est la chambre de mon petit
garçon c'est juste qu'on a
si guillaume ne trouve pas un logement
convenable il risque de perdre la garde
de son enfant ce qui va arriver mais je
vais juste d'avoir perdu la garde de mon
fils en semaine sur deux mais à
châteauguay trouver un trois et demi
abordable est devenu presque impossible
studio faute de logement chantal
hurtubise doit elle aller vivre avec son
fils benoît dagenais risque lui de
perdre son logement le propriétaire veut
tout démolir pour faire des condos
le nouveau propriétaire est fait tout
reprocher des 20 seulement dernier my en
lui la laveuse sécheuse chacun un peu
plus la vis ils sont victimes de la
crise du logement à châteauguay le
pourcentage d'appartements disponibles a
fondu de 1,1 à 0,7 pour cent en 2020
dans les banlieues de montréal le taux
d'inoccupation est à peine 2 1%
les appartements libres se trouvent
souvent dans les nouvelles constructions
trop cher inaccessible c'est pas trop
wable des prix abordables l'apport de
plus la hausse de loyers enregistrée en
2020 et la plus forte depuis près de 20
ans c'est vraiment dur d'arriver quand
tu dis que tu es monoparentales c'est un
stress qui est assez c'est dur à gérer
sur les épaules s'appauvrissent les
comités de logement s'inquiètent ils
reçoivent les appels de locataires qui
doivent maintenant choisir entre manger
ou payer le loyer se sait déjà qu'ils
travaillent une majorité de femmes et
déjà qu'ils travaillent 40 45 mille
dollars par année
on s'attend un 1er juillet difficile
montréal de devenir le prochain toronto
le prochain vancouver le 28 mars
des dizaines de personnes ont fait la
file à verdun dans l'espoir de louis un
cadre ennemis à 975 $ aux défis
l'attendent déjà sur les réseaux sociaux
dit souvent malheureusement délicate
avant de renchérir pour tous que les
trois espère c'est de trouver d'ici
juillet un logement convenable quasiment
à rien d'abordable 6 à châteauguay
signe de besoin criant pour de nouveaux
logements sociaux ici vincent
maisonneuve radio-canada châteaubourg